hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my YouTube viewers
Hafeez who watch one of my videos that I
suggested people follow their passion
and wrote in saying that you know didn't
know what their passion was and wanted
some advice on how to find it so thank
you for the question it's a great one a
lot of people do struggle to find what
their passion is and be able to turn
that into a business so my best advice
comes from my own personal experience
and hopefully I can help you as you try
to figure what your passion is when
you're struggling to find out what your
passion is it can be an exciting time
because it could be anything right that
the options are infinite you could do
whatever you want as an entrepreneur
when I sold my my first software company
I was stuck in the place where I had to
figure out what to do next I didn't have
to go out and work because I had no
money from the sale but you know I
wanted to do something with my life I
wanted to still give back and provide
value and have a lot of fun but didn't
know really what to do next
whenever you're starting the business
you want to try to offer as much value
as you can and the money you're gonna
make from that and the the fulfillment
that you're gonna get from that is gonna
come from how much value you give people
and how helpful you can be so you want
to start a business around something
that you feel you can help others with
so turning what you're excited about
what you're passionate about and turning
that into ways you help people so it's
your first kind of brainstorming
exercise to look at what do you do that
you can help people with him and where
do you you know help people on they they
really appreciate it you get a lot of
excitement and energy and joy from as I
you know sold that business what I
started to do was I was trying to figure
out what to do next I kept a little
journal of what I was doing and a day-in
day-out and tried to think about the the
moments in my professional career that
got me really excited where I got a lot
of hi and from there you know you can
try to design a business around it so
ideally as an entrepreneur you can
structure the company however you want
to structure the company and you want to
make it around something that gives you
a lot of excitement and enjoyment so I
found that creating that journal really
helped me for that period of
in my life were I was able to record
what I really like doing and what I
didn't really like doing so much and
around what I really enjoyed doing was
helping entrepreneurs connecting with
entrepreneurs meeting people you know
knowing that I was able to help their
businesses and from there I was able to
build a new business out of that so
hopefully that helps you the other thing
that I found was you don't have to
commit to something right away so after
I sold my business I didn't know what I
was gonna do next I you know was looking
at a couple of opportunities what I was
interested in at the time was raising
capital because you know we hadn't
really done it for our business
everything was bootstrap from the
beginning but I was interested in the
process of raising capital so I
connected with the venture capital
company in my city and started helping
them raise capital for entrepreneurs and
learning about that process and that was
something that was interesting for me I
didn't know if it was gonna be a new
career choice or a new business it was
just something that was interesting so I
was just following one of my potential
passions and I was curious to learn more
about it and that led me to eventually
starting Evan chimerical com where are
the sharing resources and information
and I was you know able to leave the
venture capital business after a couple
years to want to start my own business
all over again
now that happened because I wasn't
committed to you know starting a new
business right away I didn't know what I
wanted to do and the best thing to do
when you're you know trying to figure
that out
it's trial aughts of different things
and see what sticks so if you're
interested in something you think you
might be able to help people in a
certain way just start trying it and see
if you enjoy it see if you get a lot of
pleasure from it see if you are able to
help people out so you don't have to
make this huge big plan at the beginning
and a lot of people get stuck in the
planning phases and then don't actually
end up ever doing anything and you can
get stuck planning for so long you
create this fantastic plan and then you
launch your business and you don't like
what you're doing there didn't work out
the way you think it was gonna work out
and it never works out the way you think
you're gonna work out so the best way is
just start start small fail small see if
you like it if you like it a little bit
try it a little
more see if you like that more see if
you able to help people and from there
you'll you'll eventually hit something
that you really enjoy doing that you re
without a lot of value to people's lives
and you wanna you want to pursue more
you want to make it your life's mission
you want to start a business around it
and continue to move forward with it so
don't be afraid of starting small and
trying something that you're kind of
interested in but you don't have to
commit yourself to doing go once try it
see if you like it or not and kind of
build from there and eventually start
hitting on points that you find are
really interesting for you and you're
able to help a lot of people with so
hopefully that helps for those watching
I'd love to hear we have to think I love
to hear you found your passion and how
you started your business if you want to
leave a comment under the video or if
you have a question that's why I can
leave it in the comments and if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up it encourages me to want to make more
of these videos for you guys so please
give the video a thumbs up and we'll see
you on the next episode
you